the very latest in electronic gadgetry
goes on display in Las Vegas
starting tomorrow CES formerly known as
the Consumer Electronics Show is a
showcase for innovation displaying
amazing new products that raise the bar
on personal tech here to talk about
what's hot at this year's show is Jason
Tim's the site director at wired Jason
good morning good morning all right
let's start first with augmented and
virtual reality VR people know about I
think to some degree AR what is it is
this the year for it
sure well it's already been the year for
last year was kind of the year for it to
be on I'm late yes sorry
AR is it'll it projects a virtual world
on top of the real world so imagine if
I'm looking at you right now and I see I
don't know a lion right exactly but I
can still see the set behind you so it's
it's so it it puts a digital layer on
top of the real world and the real
breakthrough for that this last year was
when Apple released a our kit which is
part of its new iPhone suite so you can
hold up your phone and you can sort of
see a virtual world on top of the real
world just most recently magic leap
which is this company that's gotten a
ton of press it's been very secretive
and now's that they are going to be
releasing their headset in 2018 so so
there's a lot of energy and excitement
around AR I do think we haven't yet
there gonna be plenty of headsets that
are gonna be at CES I'm not sure that we
know yet what the killer app is you know
what are these things actually good for
I don't think we know yet seeing me as a
lion yeah that sounds pretty amazed at
succeeding yeah LG is showing an 88 inch
8k TV yes but you say actually the
really exciting thing is flexible small
screens yeah I mean every year or every
few years you know there's the new it's
HD it's 4k now it's 8k because as soon
as these why do I need 8k just static
right I have no idea I want things to be
less realistic yeah but but what I do
find interesting we've started to see
some prototypes of actual bendable
foldable screens yes and you know people
been talking about this for a while but
we've actually started seeing these
prototypes from companies like Lenovo
you know you can bend them around your
wrist and that actually does open up
some ideas about if we it's videos
amazing I know isn't it crazy
if screens were not just giant
rectangles heavy giant rectangles but
they were things that you could turn
into glasses you know other kinds of
lenses other kinds of form factors you
know what could you do with that and I
think that's a pretty interesting
intellectual exercise Jason there's
something called an always connected PC
which sounds intriguing and slightly
terrifying
well I don't need any more terrifying
than a phone basically these are a new
breed of computer that operate kind of
like a phone but with the power of a PC
so imagine a computer that logs on
instantly boots up instantly I should
say that has LTE connection that lasts
for 20 hours battery life that and that
operates kind of like a phone but with
the power of a PC we've just started
seeing the first models of these roll
out there's some partnerships between
Qualcomm and Microsoft and we're going
to see a few of those devices this year
as well
Amazon had a huge Christmas with its
virtual assistant echo Google has home
apple is expected to launch something I
mean are these things finally gaining
really broad acceptance oh absolutely
they are you know last year I think I
was on talking about like who needs an
internet-connected washing machine and
this has been the big question forever
like yeah yeah that's right you take a
device and you stick the internet on it
because you can but who cares I do think
that you know with voice commands
suddenly that does start feeling a
little more interesting right now if
you're in your living room you say hey
Google how much more time and there's my
wash cycle going to be that's at least
sort of interesting but I do think that
there is some resistance to all these
connected devices over the last year
with all the security breaches and I'm
curious to see if any of that works its
way in to see yes as well I want it to
say hey Google fold the laundry I don't
think we're gonna give it a couple days
okay yeah next year
Jason Tan great to see you man likewise
thanks